Dan Attias, Director, Producer and Author: I
thought I had to know everything in advance.
I thought I had to be the authority coming in.
I thought I had to be…I couldn't confess to not
knowing something. I was reluctant to ask too
many questions because I thought that would…
Film Courage: What mistakes did you make
directing your first episode of television?
Dan: Yeah that was early in my career. I
write a chapter about it in my book it's
the second chapter I call it the school of hard
knocks I had wanted to be and I grew up as a
I watched films in the 60s and 70s
and kind of loved the independent
cinema world and really aspired that's what I
want to do I want to make I want to be an auteur
and my first job was a feature film in 1984
Stephen King's Silver Bullet I'm not a horror
aficionado but that was that was kind of often the
the the way in horror films to get good directing
credits and and after I did that I was determined
I don't want to do a feature I don't want to do
a horror film for next I want my next film to
reflect more of my sensibility even though I'm
pleased that it now seems to have a kind of a
cult following and I enjoy people telling me oh
that was a film I really liked but I didn't want
to do more horror films and so I was I went into
trying to find material I liked went into what
they call development hell on a couple of things
and I became I got in my own way a lot I became
so so critical about anything anything that was
offered that I didn't really I wasn't very quick
to attach to things and because I wasn't terribly
experienced I wasn't offered the the great scripts
I was offered things that really required work
and as I was developing material which never wound
up getting made I was offered some television
shows and I thought of television well television
this was in the mid 80s and at that time
the so-called golden age hadn't hit the second one
of course the original one was the live television
age but and and so it really wasn't I didn't take
it very seriously as an artistic form but I took
I said okay well maybe I can take some of this
work to just develop my chops as a director and
one of the first jobs I was offered was Miami Vice
in its third season and that was the cool show
and it's interesting too because Miami
Vice which was spearheaded by Michael Mann
was was a bit snobby about who they hired
as director they only wanted to hire
feature directors which I qualified for because I
had that feature but what I knew about directing
then compared to what I know about directing
through directing series television was like
a thimble compared to an ocean and but still
I was hired for the job and I came into it
with all kinds of ideas that really got in my
way one of which was I thought I had to know
everything in advance I thought I had to be
the authority coming in I thought I had to be
I couldn't confess to not knowing something I
was reluctant to ask too many questions because
I thought that would somehow erode my authority
and I and I even I kidded myself I lied to myself
about things and I so I didn't first of all do
as much prep as I needed to do I didn't really
immerse myself in the story I thought no because
I had a kind of romantic vision then too of what
directing was so you have to be open creatively
in the moment well I've since found it to be most
open in the moment for me I have to be fully
prepared and then I can be free enough to be
open and trust the answers that will come from me
but then I didn't think that so I started working
on Miami Vice and that was like at that time Don
Johnson was known as the king of Miami and he he
was a director himself and I was very new to film
language I didn't I didn't have security about how
do you how do you what my shot list wasn't never
sure like screen direction and what shots do I
need to cut the sequence well and I'd kind of come
up with an idea but when I'd show up on the set
Don Johnson would frequently say no how about we
do this and he talked to the camera and he'd start
walking all over me essentially which was
humiliating but what was what was equally
challenging was that his ideas were better which I
recognized so I constantly felt well I'm okay so I
felt my my my confidence sapped and everything
else in addition I didn't know the way of the
world in episodic television and I didn't really
understand the inner workings the inner politics
of it all and I was shooting in Miami while the
producers the creative team was in los angeles and
I was communicating everything that I wanted to do
to the to the line producer in Miami thinking that
was equivalent to talking to the other producers
and when I shot a sequence I won't go into the
details of it but I fixed something that was
problematic for the budget and the linebridge yeah
great and then when the producers saw dailies they
freaked out because I hadn't cleared it with them
and suddenly I became a fair target because part
of that show is everybody was trying to be cooler
than everybody else and everybody was looking
for a scapegoat if it wasn't like a super cool
show and so I became a lightning rod suddenly
because I had I had done something that hadn't
been cleared and then I made a neophyte's mistake
I didn't haven't read the script carefully enough
and I misread the transfer of a body from the
trunk of one car to the truck on another and I
had I missed it I had to go the other way because
it had made story sense in a different way than
what the writer had imagined but I wasn't even
conscious that I was changing it I just misread it
I mean to this day I can't figure out why the
script supervisor didn't tell me hey it's written
this way it's the other way but anyway and as soon
as that happened in addition to not having shot
the sequence as it had been written it was it
was just a horrifically challenging experience
and there were a few other things that happened
and and I didn't know if I was ever going to work
again in television at that point I was still
more concerned with features but it was it was
very painful and there were other things about it
that were difficult the episode turned out well
actually and it and it gave me confidence that
oh I do know how to tell a story and despite
no support and despite my own self-judgments
and self-recriminations I thought it works
the performances all were delivered the story
was told well but it was hard to overcome those
original impressions and I didn't get another
job for several months because that was my only
reference and it wasn't a good one and I the next
job I got was on another show that period called
beauty and the beast and that also was a popular
show and it's interesting it was for those of
you it's a it's a retelling of the story was ron
pearlman played a lion-like mythological character
who lived below the new york subways and that
was the underworld and linda hamilton played the
beauty in the upper world and she would come he
was I think she was a news reporter and she would
come down and they had this intense romance which
was very romantic and and the story I was given
was an interesting one because it was about
a young man who who had a very intolerant
father single father and he was miserable
the father could not credit the young boy's
interest in his own imagination and the the
show runner of beauty and the beast knew that
I was interested I don't know how it was he
knew that I was at that time doing workshops
and reading a lot of robert bleis work with men
and and his partner a mythologist michael mead
who still is doing great work up in seattle but
I was very interested in initiation male young
males initiations and this story seemed to be
right up its alley and the showrunner actually
called me and said you're interested in this let's
let's work on this because that's what this story
is about and I was very excited about it and I
started filming oh and I and I learned from the
experience with vice that my problem was I hadn't
been willing to admit what I didn't know I hadn't
immersed myself in the story enough so I could
take full responsibility for every aspect of the
storytelling and and would develop a shot a shot
list and a way of seeing that I could defend and
not just be a deer in the headlights when somebody
had another idea so I spent my entire prep
overcoming my reluctance to admit what I didn't
know asking if I could spend time on the sets
after hours on the weekends even if it made me
look like someone who was it was their first job
and I spent and it was a real it was a
real epiphany for me because I took total
responsibility for every moment being communicated
I lived on the sets I absorbed them as if they
were characters themselves I acted out in my
imagination all the scenes I developed staging
ideas because I wanted I didn't want to come in
again not knowing and which starts with admitting
what you don't know admitting what questions need
answering that's what I hadn't done on the first
job and it became very exhilarating to me so
that I emerged with a vision of how to tell the
story and then I could enlist the help of all the
collaborators all they want to hear is what you
want to do and what what vision you're trying to
hold then they bring their creativity and it was
thrilling and I started directing and within the
first three or four two or three days they really
the producers were over the moon they they called
me and said oh my god these are the most beautiful
dailies we've ever had the performances are
amazing and on the I think the fourth day or
they came to me and said you're the showrunner
came to me and said you're the director I most
trust our next episode is the most important one
can you do it and I said wow I don't know I mean
I'd love to but it's a holiday let me check with
my wife and we can work it out for our family and
I said okay good and he says great. so I had
about three more days of filming and about two
days later there was some shift that happened it
was very bizarre suddenly they weren't calling me
and and I shot a scene for the ending of the show
and the pr the showrunner finally did call me and
I could tell he was furious at me and I said what
he's you didn't shoot a close-up of the father
and I said well we can shoot it tomorrow
if you want it but the reason I didn't is
the story we had discussed doing in advance
was that this was a story of an initiation
and that the story not to get too involved about
it but the boy travels to the underworld finds an
inner father who will bless him who is embodied by
ron perlman's beast and it allows him to survive
the intolerant other father and and that a key
initiatory challenge is to develop containment
so the scene the showrunner was asking me about
is when he re-emerges from the underworld and
the father is there to greet him with
with the battalion of firemen and police
and linda hamilton's character is also there
and the father embraces him who's never
touched him the whole episode he's just been
angry at him the key moment is the look between
linda hamilton and the boy in the while he's
in the embrace of the father is he going to
stay with containing what he knows because if he
reveals the existence of the underworld it will be
it's undoing and so he looks at linda hamilton she
looks at him and they understand in that moment
that he's going to contain this and so he's been
blessed he's going to he's on his way to manhood
and that was the story to cut to a
close-up of the father I thought would
muddy the his feelings were not the appropriate
thing so I said that's what I thought the story
was but if you want us to get this other moment
I will get it tomorrow which we did and when I
finished the episode expecting to start the
next day on the on the the following episode
I was told there's been some rethinking about
this and you'll report to the showrunner's
office tomorrow and I felt like I was
being summoned to the principal's office
but what happened was I showed up and it reminded
me of a scene I don't know if any of your viewers
saw the movie network but there was a famous
scene when peter finch's anchorman character
comes in to meet with ned beatty's producer
character in a conference room and ned beatty
just glowers over him and says do what you're
[ __ ] with that was that was the feeling I had
that was my god this guy starts telling me and
he's I remember his opening words he says I was
seduced by your beautiful style and I missed that
you have absolutely no capacity to elicit emotion
and I said what what's going on I said because
that was the one thing I'd never been accused of
I'm good very good with actors and getting in and
that's also I was flattered because I didn't have
a visual plan in the previous episode and now he
said I had a beautiful visual style so that was
great and I said what are you talking about
and something had shifted in him and he had
developed made a case against me and what I came
to understand is he had gotten cold feet about his
the whole thrust of the episode we had agreed upon
going in because it's interesting show runners
get to inhabit a very exalted position you
really feel like you're on top of the world
you can even be a star yourself as a showrunner
and if your show gets cancelled it can be like
going from the penthouse to the basement boom
like that and you could just join the throng
of throngs of unemployed writers and I think
he started to feel like wait we're not giving
our audience the sentimentality the
romantic sentimentality we usually
they tune in for and and I said well and
I realized that I understood this goes to
an earlier question you asked me it's like
what what the audience's expectations were I
understood that that was an element of the
show and I thought that actually we were
enhancing the romance between Lynn Hamilton and
Ron perlman's characters by virtue of the fact
that they were playing surrogate roles surrogate
parental roles with this young boy and they were
bonding together as they were doing that but the
story I was handed was not a sentimental story
it was a I thought a much more tough-minded one
and a much more meaningful one and I think he got
cold feet I think he got worried that I wasn't
so hence the need for a sentimental shot of the
father at exactly the wrong time but he had made
a case against me and his producers who were just
very slavish to him were supporting him and
all that and he said you even undermined the
key visual stuff moments in the show there are
visual uh highlights I said what are you talking
about and he said there was a visual trick they
use on every episode when when you go into the
underworld you walk into the subway tunnels
and you'd enter what looked like a skylight
but it was a super bright light and as soon as
the character goes in they just would disappear
and he said you didn't shoot that and I looked at
the producer who was on set with me when I didn't
shoot it and he didn't say a word I said well the
reason we didn't shoot is the light malfunctioned
on the day and I knew we have to come back
at expense great expense another time which
we could certainly do but I said while we're here
maybe there's a way around it maybe the boy could
approach the light could be photographed it's just
when someone went into it they wouldn't disappear
so maybe the boy could be moving towards it and
then we could cut to linda hamilton watching him
disappear as the audience would assume he had and
turn away I said if it doesn't work fine we have
to come back we'd have to come back anyway but if
it does work we have it but he was convinced I was
actively trying to sabotage him so it was a crazy
crazy experience and now I'd had two terrible
experiences in terms of future references and I
thought am I ever going to work again and I did
finally of course get another job several months
later and ironically it was with a showrunner who
had worked on beauty and the beast and didn't
care at all about what had been said because
he had been on staff there and had seen these
exact kinds of accusations leveled routinely at
other people himself included you're undermining
the show or whatever so he says I don't I don't
care about any of that and on this show it was
it was interesting I started working on it I
applied the same lessons I'd learned from the
need to really prep and get fully immersed
I started shooting and on the second or third
day I got a phone message and I'm listening and
it says oh it was producer director we love
your dailies the performances are great we
just couldn't be happier and I remember I was
in San Francisco I was walking to the set and I
just remember just dropping the phone hey boy am I
glad I had that experience on beauty and the beast
so I know not to take any of that seriously and
I stopped myself thinking wow is that really
what I feel I'm glad for having gone through
that horrible experience and I realized I was
because it had acquainted me with so much about
the nature of these shows and what the political
interactions are and sensitizing me to that I
mean if if they hadn't liked the show I would have
what I was doing I would certainly want to hear
about it and I'd try to accommodate them but I
knew that I wasn't going to be so dependent
anymore on with someone else's opinion I'm
not and I'm not going to necessarily assume I'm at
fault or go into a dark hole if a choice I've made
isn't agreed with so that was that was big but
what was most important what I realized was that
the real gift of beauty and the beast was the
experience I had before it ever blew apart when
I knew to just go on the set spend which I do to
this day just immerse myself in the story to find
out what I care about find out what might need to
be changed for me to care about it more find out
in advance what walls might need to be made wild
meaning you could take it out when you're shooting
away from it but put it back in when you're
shooting towards it giving you a better frame
all of those things I learned
to just to and to just to be
fully take full responsibility for the
storytelling that was the real gift of
beauty and the beast and I've i've made use of
those gifts I think for the rest of my career
and so do you think that it's more detrimental
to the set to have a director who yells
and is somewhat of a bully or a director
that doesn't own their authority
yeah I think set demeanor is is is a
is a is a real issue and one of the
requirements one of the realities of being a
director is that you're the one in command and you
can either accept the responsibilities that come
with that except take ownership of that role or
not now there's all kinds of ways to take
ownership of that there's all kinds of ways
to to have command and to demonstrate command
it does not mean you have to be commanding
I think as I've thought about it I wrote a chapter
called interstates in my book that addresses this
among a few other things I think those who have
command are those who the the crew and the cast
they have to feel it within you there is a there
there that you're taking responsibility for the
storytelling and that and that the buck stops with
you now I think the best leaders are those who are
willing to acknowledge what they don't yet know
and are and are interested in collaborating and
are interested in getting the best from the people
around them because there are so many people that
have expertise that I as the director don't have
the director of photography knows far more about
about light sensitivity and lensing and all that
than I do I have ideas and I’ll make suggestions
but I cut off my nose to spite my face if
I insist if I don't if I'm not interested
at least in hearing another point of view same
with same with production designers and and prop
people and and and and wardrobe and hair all these
people what I try to do is is carry a vision for
what story communicate a vision for what story I'm
telling where I think the emotional reality lies
where what subjective state I'm hoping to create
for individual scenes communicate that without
telling necessarily how to achieve that and
so someone and then then you're enlisting the
creativity of everybody to come up with
ways I might never have thought about so
so how to get the best from your
collaborators is I think the mark of
getting the best from your collaborators I
think is the mark of a good leader we all
have insecurities we all have our personalities
we bring into it one of the one of the things
that is a constant learning for me and I earlier
in my career it was not something I could always
hold in mind is how much people project onto
you as the director you're the authority figure
now you probably experience yourself as the
flawed human being that we all are but when
you're in a position of authority other people
are looking to you and as the director you have
the great great power to influence their own sense
of job security or even self-worth if they project
who knows what they're projecting on you so it's
important to accept that role and to be and to be
i would say benign that's not to say I mean that
also means sometimes you have to set boundaries
you have to hold people accountable it
doesn't mean you're always saying yes to
everything or it's a love fest sometimes
people don't measure up and don't don't
take responsibility for their own areas
they need to take responsibility for
and I think as a leader you need to make that
clear that you expect better but when you are
abrupt and dictatorial it doesn't it doesn't
make me want to cooperate with that person
and I assume that's how others are going to react
and I think it also betrays an insecurity that
people at a deeper level understand so which
also makes people uneasy regardless of how
they're being treated personally they don't
feel they're in good hands they don't feel
actors for example may not feel the story is
going to get told well because this person
is insecure and is just not listening to
me won't even hear it they're too rigid so
there's that problem and then there's
also the problem when when you
when a director doesn't take responsibility you
can always feel that when you walk on the set
because there's a kind of vacuum there no one
really knows who's going to make the decision
and that leads to an innervation and a kind of you
don't get your the best from your collaborators
I think there's a baseball metaphor I like
which is the the pitchers with the best control
are the ones for whom the defense plays better
because they know like for example if a batter
comes up I don't know if many any many of you are
baseball fans but like on a diamond if you pitch
someone if a right-handed ears up and you pitch
on the outside the likelihood is going to hit
the ball more to the right side they're not going
to be able to get around so if the infielders see
that the catcher is signaling for the ball
to come to the outside and they know they can
count on their pitcher to hit that spot they'll
gravitate more to that side and be in better
position to feel it if the pitcher's wild and
throw it anywhere they don't know what to do so
taking responsibility makes everybody feel feel
I think more willing to contribute themselves so
long as the one taking responsibility
is respectful and interested in what
they the others can bring you mentioned the
director's role in being benign I think you
used some example of a francois truffaut yeah film
where there was a hearing yeah as it related yeah
yeah well director's role yeah one of the things
that's that's not often spoken about is and
I haven't read a lot of the literature that's been
written about directing but the that I the that
the ones that the books that I have seen and also
just the discussion generally about directing and
and when I talk to young directors and the people
no one seems particularly interested or aware
necessarily of the wide range of emotional
challenges that you face as the director the
stresses the bombardment with questions the need
to come up with answers all the insecurities and
and different moods the impatience you can get
when something isn't happening fast enough or
when an actor isn't understanding something
or it's like it can it can create such a wide
variety of emotional states that one of the really
important qualities to develop is is I think of
it as mindfulness is willing as containment is
being willing to acknowledge what's happening
within you and still keep your see the forest
for the trees and keep your eyes on the prize and
maybe a few more cliches I could throw in but to
to so so that there are these these stressors as
a director is this good am I getting this oh my
god it's night time we are only on this three more
scenes the most important scene is the end of the
day and I'm gonna have to rush it because I have
all these things you have to constant prioritizing
and always trying to think and my way through by
the way is to always emphasize story that that's
the thing I have to focus on what's the story
point what's how if I have to simplify something
I don't want to simplify I don't want to lose a
story point I might sac have to sacrifice
a beautiful shot that was time-consuming
but getting a beautiful shot and
missing the story is not even a
consideration you gotta I for me anyway
you've got to keep telling the story and
one of the one of the one of the states that
I mentioned in my book that you cite is that
francois truffaut brilliant filmmaker one
maybe my very favorite film director maybe
my very favorite film is the 400 blows buddha
souffle she made in 1959 which I didn't see
when it came out but I saw a little after and
it's a beautiful film autobiographical film
he made another wonderful film several but one
in particular called la nui american which was
translated as day for night and that's
the term that a film term when you shoot
a night sequence in the middle of the day by
stopping down the camera a lot of westerns used
to do that so when you see a western and it's like
it's night but you're seeing everything across the
plain and everybody well you didn't they didn't
like that whole thing what they did is they
they limited the exposure to the film
so that it would just look darker
so anyway that was that's a film term but in day
for night he played he played a director of a film
coming together it's a wonderful film and one of
the things I love about it too is it it really
does capture the feeling of what it can be like
even on series television when you when you've
worked for a period of time and you've worked
with various different crews and you move around
and crews spread out and the makeup person from
this show is winds up oh and this new show oh I
know you and and the the key grip is some oh yeah
remember we worked on so this show was great it
showed everybody kind of coming together in this
whole world getting created to create this film
and truffaut played the director and he was
dealing in this little sly twist I thought
everybody's coming to him they're producing we
don't have enough money and he said okay we'll
deal with that and the actor's saying and I just
got out of the psychiatric ward and I left him
and his we have to deal with that and okay I'm
dealing with that and then the star and it's like
all and everybody's coming in with questions and
he gave his character a hearing aid so that he
could just simply sometimes just say I can't hear
you and it's like and I thought that was really
a great little twist because it's like I thought
it just spoke to a fantasy many director's habits
would be nice sometimes just tune it all out just
give me a break let me just let me just chill
for a minute but the reality is the director's
the one person who can't be missing in action.